tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video di among us oggi
facciamo una roba un po particolare
perché durante una partita
mi sono scocciato di posizione con
charlie moon per vedere che cosa giusto
per mettere un po più di casinò nella
partita durante questa partita d'altro
ci chiamiamo tutti ciao per incasinare
maggiormente le idee insomma un bordello
però buona visione
[Musica]
ciao 7 sono io ciao 3 siamo impostori e
faremo uno switch a metà partita dove a
un certo punto giochi era charlie al
posto mio
quindi a metà partita switch amo e
vediamo che succede tanto sto qua in
elettrica
faccio finta di fare una tasca e me ne
vado ciao 3 st quantità e grecia o tre
tra l'altro io non capendo chi sono gli
altri non so quanto potremo più che in
base a come sa chi sono le varie le
varie persone so come comportarmi
proprio perché non ne ho idea cosa vuoi
ciao blu spiega mi vuol fare ciao blu
cacchio stavo venendo giù da admin verso
electrical per fissare le luci non
vedevo niente ma passando in reaktor non
l'ha visto appunto ha portato a posto
vorrei ammazzare che noia ma non so chi
è che noi e rosso ma vieni qui vieni qua
tanto chissenefrega bassi a non farli
quando sono il monte chiede che noi ad
essere nero il nero e che noia
e allora vado lì la qualcuno viene
elettrica no porco demonio che chiudevo
le porte se per caso qualcuno entra in
elettrica
no mi chiama può esserci ciao 66 64
il blu e il blu ragazza oblucki comunque
non sa che io credo di fare ciao blu io
lo voto
e lui ma che siete miei e lo sta così è
che stavolta io sono giunte due il
nostro ma posso dire la stessa cosa
perché già ucciso proprio davanti a me
dove va bene cathay cia se vota ciao 3
se non è lui co2 ok a mano che ho quasi
finito le tasche da qualcuno interessato
però non si vede riempire che ha votato
dai che abbiamo ragione eccolo da mi
consigli che ne so dove devo andare
allora gli allora poi non andare non
andare in elettrica che ci sei già stata
tre volte ma il navigation ok
vai navigation e fai fai finta di non
fare mai stai facendo e ora si da sola
però se non fossi stata la sola vari
storia devo decidere qualcuno dai a
matera dove trovarlo alcune occupare
questi tempi per favore io e lo dici a
tua moglie
ma cosa è perché vi chiediamo scusa sia
usato il nulla penso faccio una manica
che mi sa che è morto si genera quindi
232 mazza non devi starci vicino di
ricordo ci ha giustamente demonio devi
ammazzare certo non meno fa niente
potremmo tenere un processo che portò
riportato no fai quella cosa di prima di
note ma mai cosa fai tu ma lei ci sono
volti a me arabi dispiace perché ciao
666 può confermare che io stavo facendo
l'ossigeno su sono arrivata i nostri
giorno giu e tu mi hai ucciso il coso
davanti ci sono tanti ha però la sto
facendo una città incredibile come ci
sono fatti nuovi episodi non si può
onestamente non mi fido troppo di cesca
quindi voterò cielo 6 ma infatti ma
nemmeno io ma scusami regala perché ai
no
ma darà meno vicino motivo a casa
madonna
insomma è giusta finalmente ho vinto una
partita da impostore facciamole tasco
cia moneta speciale task la med che
l'audio youservice spendere tanto è
forse la prima volta che il video perché
non la faccio mai
perché non l'hai possano mai le tasche
non è la prima volta comunque hanno
aumentato le tasse che perché ormai
ragazzi siete stati talmente bravi che
che le tasche devono essere veramente
aumentate sono quasi siamo in cinque
minuti ma fa niente perché tanto sono
comunque fini gonzalez va bene lo stesso
quest'anno viene elettrica al meno male
meno male sono già qua forno che
benissimo
bravo vessicchio e la fase finito questa
strage
io prenderei che si può essere i veri
play che sono marci step quelli che
sanno ventare mai guardato i video io
vento un botto la capra non sono
tranquilli ragazzi mi puzza un sacco sta
storia però vabbè chissenefrega admin
secondo me stesso non me la conta ma non
me la conta giusta ma neanche per
sbaglio mi dispiaceva ucciderlo subito
perché farò registra almeno però non mi
raccontano giustizia e poi comunque non
ho dei sospetti sono su di lui anche
somari ci penso amaro ma non è detto che
non si sa non posso avere una conferma
ha detto questo se facevo di fianco
quindi come come mi ammazza avremmo
subito la conferma ma c'è anche l'arci
comunque è sicuro che chi che
l'impostore sa fare bene perché è
affatto pensa al 100 per cover stessi
morto stelle generalmente con la tema io
scherzavo prima fiere fede perché rivi
[Risate]
il fatto che giovane rita o una
supposizione ha vinto anche lo hai certo
perché fair era con me in store e di
salatini shields ha aperto la schermata
provato stefano
bene in mente cosa fixare le luci
facendo il giro zio perenne passata di
bianco per uccidermi tantissimo chi sta
qua marce ok perfetto nel mar cm 100 100
e nate per forza fermi avrebbe ucciso
nat cacchio per è vero ci sono le crisi
fatela fix l'ice mi ammazzerà prima
allora non sono voluto stare vicino a
much perché sono avevo fatto così dei
metalli eni comunque perché ho messo
nelle gambe
no no e no allora io sono nessuno di voi
quindi o è noto e fa vi sono gli uffici
tolentino ma devono bianco elettrica che
nessuno ha fatto nulla scusa al posto di
le luci posso dire la mia famiglia stava
sopra è marcio ferro visto dalle
telecamere andare giù veramente il
marcio è morto quindi dal tf no non mi
lasciate il voto finale ragazzo 50 per
cento cinquanta per cento la macumba
farò un'idea ragazzi non della fipa
linea bando prin al islam o completely
random
oddio ci vogliono per i favi gotico un
video cioè tu stavi sopra è da solo io
stavo alle telecamere ma qualcosa bravo
sismi pensiero tantissimi bravi pensiero
[Musica]
tantissimi ragazzi spero che il video vi
sia piaciuta questa era per la volta che
mi scambia i con charlie non violiamo
incalza lasciato questo mi piace i
schede da canale e noi come sempre ci
vediamo se non mi sfascio lo studio da
ragazzi
[Musica]